could you tell me how to detect a  narcissist we have a culture right now  that seems to just diagnose everybody  with narcissism yes immediately i'm like  well hang on there have to be degrees i  look for things like can someone  actually say they're sorry a very simple  thing can someone say you're right what  i did wasn't great that wasn't a good  thing to do well that was a selfish  thing to do and they reflect and have  the self-awareness of knowing that they  did something that wasn't okay or at the  very minimum was an intensely hurtful  thing to do and i don't think people who  don't apologize are automatically  narcissists but i do think that it's one  of those character traits that it freaks  me out being around people who can't  apologize that's fair yeah